[DIGITAL JINGLE]
MELISSA MORALES: Let's get
started and talk a little bit
about SheFighter.
LINA KHALIFEH: So thank you.
Yeah-- go ahead.
MELISSA MORALES:
Yeah, yeah, yeah-- no.
LINA KHALIFEH: Thank you so
much for bringing me to Google.
Actually, Google filmed a
documentary about SheFighter
last year.
But it's funny.
You can find it on my
website, shefighter.com.
But it's funny that
they filmed me running
all the time in the streets.
And I told them,
I'm not a runner.
I fight.
And they're like, no.
We want more if you running.
I'm like, fine.
We did a lot of running.
So if you see, like,
just me running,
that's Google, from that
documentary about it.
MELISSA MORALES: That's called
the Google Marketing Pixie
Dust that was sprinkled
on the whole thing.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah,
but I think they
wanted to show more of
Jordan-- the history,
the streets, the people.
Because they were
all looking at me,
like, why is she running
at 4:00 in the morning?
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah-- my
name is Lina Khalifeh.
And have you heard of the
Khalifa Tower in Dubai?--
the tallest one in the world?
I don't own it.
[LAUGHTER]
If I owned it, I would come with
a private jet, like "vvvv"--
just land here.
I started SheFighter
in 2012 with the idea
of solving the
problem for violence
against women in
the Middle East.
Honestly, I had enough.
I had enough from women telling
me, we cannot do anything.
We have no solution.
We're weak.
I've heard that a lot,
especially growing up and being
raised in the Middle East.
So what I did--
I had a background in taekwondo.
I started 5-years-old,
training taekwondo.
And the reason why I started
it-- because my parents
want me to stay away
from the streets.
I used to beat up boys a lot.
And they're like, OK, we
need Lina off the streets.
So if you see that
scar, it's actually
one of the fights with the boys.
And yeah-- they enrolled
me in a taekwondo school.
And from that time, I got
so addicted to martial arts.
I loved it.
It became part of my
personality-- my identity.
And that's where I
wanted also, later on,
to start something for women.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah--
that's incredible.
So speaking of getting
into fights with boys--
LINA KHALIFEH: All the time--
MELISSA MORALES: Tell us
a little bit about some
of the challenges that
you've faced along the way
in starting SheFighter
and helping grow it.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, definitely.
So I started SheFighter
because my friend
got beaten up and abused
by her brother and father
when I was at the university.
And she was just my colleague.
And I got really upset.
I told her, why
didn't you report?
Why don't you do something?
And she said, we
cannot do anything.
Women cannot do anything.
I got so pissed off.
I said, I don't have a lot
of power and knowledge.
But what I know
is training women
how to defend themselves-- how
to stand up for themselves.
And I started at the basement
of my parents' house.
And it was in 2009.
And in 2012, I took
it very seriously.
And I started SheFighter,
the first self-defense
to do in the Middle
East for women.
And everyone was
against the idea-- a lot
of haters everywhere, right?
And they said, it's
not going to work.
Women in the Middle
East are not interested.
They're just
interested in cooking
and just gossiping, maybe, or--
whatever-- fashion.
And I told them, no.
I believe that's right.
And that's where I did
not care about others.
It's important for you
to know that you do not
listen to people who
want to put you down.
You always have small support.
It doesn't matter.
Just hang on with the support.
And just look at the
bright side all the time.
But a lot of challenges, of
course, as you start growing.
The more you grow, the
more challenges it becomes.
And the bigger it
becomes, dealing
with market and mostly
male-dominated country,
like Jordan.
So it started from an
idea to this huge business
that we are
franchising globally.
And then the problems started
getting bigger and bigger.
They want to shut me down.
They want me they want
me off the market.
I'm changing women's lives.
I'm changing the way they think.
And they just want me out.
So one of the stories
is I got sued--
so it's a suit case-- by a man
who happened to be a lawyer.
His wife was training at
SheFighter for two years.
And she had an argument.
And she used
self-defense against him.
And she punched him in the face.
And he got so upset,
because we taught her
how to stand up for herself.
And he sued us for
teaching her self-defense.
And he said, she cannot
teach that to women.
And I thought, it's a joke.
But it wasn't a joke.
And I had to deal
with it legally.
I called my lawyer.
And they told him, there is
a stupid guy who sued us.
Now what?
And he said, let's
work on it legally.
I'm going to call him and see
what we can do from there.
Because it's a still
male-dominated country
that will support men.
And they you do whatever it
takes to protect the family.
For them, if, like, SheFighter,
is ruining some of the families
or getting more divorces--
for them, women have voices.
It means, they can put
me in jail for that.
So you need to act smart
when you work in these areas.
You cannot just keep fighting.
You need to be smart.
You just need to be smart.
So we said, we're
going to talk to him.
We're going to have
a meeting with him.
And we brought him.
So we told him,
what do you want?
Like, let's not
get this to court.
And he said, I want my wife
to be out of SheFighter.
I don't want her to
come to train anymore.
I'm like, problem solved--
it's going to be done.
And we called her.
And we told her, you have to
solve your problems at home,
dealing with your husband.
But we cannot have you
at SheFighter anymore.
But we had to work on
this in a smart way
to protect the business
from haters like him.
MELISSA MORALES:
Yeah-- and actually,
that leads me to my
next question, which
is, you're a social
entrepreneur who started small
but has really sought to scale.
And you've done these
trainer of trainers,
which is how you've been
able to really reach
a really mass audience.
I'm wondering, when
you close your eyes
and you really envision your
grand vision for SheFighter--
in 10 years, what
does that look like?
Where do you hope to achieve?
What kind of change
do you hope to effect?
LINA KHALIFEH: So definitely,
the more I inspire people,
I feel like I'm
doing my purpose.
I feel like, I'm alive.
I feel, I'm not just
a number in the world.
And my goal is to get to 1
million trainers globally.
Now, we've done 500 trainers--
certified.
And they are doing their
own workshops and trainings
in many countries, like Germany,
South Korea, and Africa,
Mauritius, in Portugal--
all over the world.
And we're bringing
it to United States.
MELISSA MORALES: Yay!
LINA KHALIFEH: So--
MELISSA MORALES: Whoo!
LINA KHALIFEH: --I'm excited
to partner up, train trainers--
just grow this movement.
Of course, the training
is not just physical.
We have a lot of
training psychological.
We call it the
philosophy of SheFighter.
It's how to actually avoid a
lot of problems in your life
by just being more
self-confident
and believing in yourself
and just standing
strong for yourself
and others as well.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
And I guess, along
those lines, you
mentioned this
internal work that you
ask people who come through the
program to engage in, right?
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: I'm curious--
what kind of
internal work do you
do to maintain your
motivation, especially
when you're thinking about
challenges that you're facing,
like the ones you described?
What kind of
processes do you have?
LINA KHALIFEH: So I realized
through my journey building
SheFighter, it's not
just building SheFighter.
I changed a lot.
I change in my mind.
I changed in the
way I view life.
I saw meeting different women
and people all over the globe.
And I started growing my mind
and expanding my mind a lot--
that I felt, life
is so beautiful,
just knowing that there
is a lot of mystery in it
and how you can solve everything
and how you grow internally.
So martial arts
helped a lot on being
more focused and disciplined.
But I realized, as I started
growing, my thoughts actually
affect a lot of decisions that
I have to make in the future.
So I started to think about
positive things all the time.
Positive doesn't mean that I
have to be happy all the time.
It's just, my thoughts on
more brighter than darker.
And if I have a dark thought,
I would think about it.
Like, why do I get that
dark thought or emotion?
And I start implementing
it in my life.
And good things started to
be attracted to my work.
Other than-- I realized,
in my students--
my journey empowering women
as well, some students--
the women--
they started having
some ego problems.
They become so strong--
stronger than men.
They can take down any man.
They're so strong.
MELISSA MORALES: Ooh!
LINA KHALIFEH: They
got so addicted--
MELISSA MORALES: OK.
LINA KHALIFEH: That's good, but
they had the problem of ego.
Of course, not all of
them, but some of them that
they felt that they're
better than others.
And it's important that
they keep this humbleness.
You know your skills.
Like, I know my skills.
I know my strength.
But I still do it for
good, not to hurt others
and not to use it for violence
or for just proving to others
that I'm the best.
You don't have to
prove to others.
You know yourself.
A lot of my students, they
started challenging me.
Like, do you want to fight?
MELISSA MORALES: Wow.
LINA KHALIFEH: Because
they want to test
if they are stronger than me.
And then I learned,
it's an ego talking.
It's not them.
They changed to
become this person who
just wants to fulfill the
ego, because it gives them
satisfaction.
So they have a problem
with self-confidence.
For me, if you want to
prove to others and yourself
that you're good,
you have a problem
with your self-confidence.
You don't know who you are.
And they need to
know who they are.
So I started talking
more training
about how to
discipline your ego,
because the ego
wanted to be fed.
Like, you want to
buy the best car.
You want to buy the best house.
Just-- it's ego talking to you.
I would feel good,
if I buy this.
I would feel good if
I win this champion--
I would feel good if I--
and it'd get me
thinking, why these girls
are behaving in that way.
And then I did all
this philosophy.
And I implemented
it in my training--
the philosophy of SheFighter.
And it talks a lot
about thoughts,
ego, discipline,
and how you create
your future and all of that.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: I really
cannot think of a better place
to deliver this message
than Silicon Valley--
my goodness.
[LAUGHTER]
So just very briefly,
I wanted to task
if you could share a brief story
of somebody in your program
that you think really
exemplifies that transition--
that evolution of coming
in, maybe not feeling super
empowered, but then
coming out the other end,
and then being what
you hope to see.
And then we'll open it up
to audience Q&A. I promise.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
So one of the stories--
one of the girls we had training
at SheFighter in Jordan.
She got attacked at the
elevator in her own building
by a stranger.
And she said, it was daytime.
I was just heading
back from work.
And there was a guy
who pushed her in.
He choked her.
And he wanted to rape her.
And that guy-- he
was in his mid 20s.
He was big.
And she freaked out.
The first thing she said--
I freaked out.
I had a pepper spray in my bag.
But everything fell.
I could not think.
And all I have is just myself.
And she could not
even scream for help.
So what she did.
She start pushing him.
She said, my mind
started reacting.
Because she is trained, right?
So she started pushing
him away from her,
until he felt like
she's resisting a lot.
So he escaped from the elevator.
She got angry and chased
him to the streets.
And she asked some
men to help her.
She said, like, thief!--
or whatever.
And everyone-- of course,
it's a macho society, right?
They all jump in on that guy.
And what she did-- she started
hitting him in the street,
because she's angry.
He touched her.
And the police
came after a while.
You know how the
police in America--
they haven't just donuts maybe?
[LAUGHTER]
In Jordan, they have falafel,
so not much different.
They came after a while.
She put charges against him
in court for sexual assault.
He put charges against her for
beating him up in the street.
But she won the case.
And he got three years
in jail for assault.
MELISSA MORALES: Wow.
LINA KHALIFEH: So that's
one of the stories.
There are so many
others, of course.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah,
yeah, yeah-- absolutely.
Well, that was some--
yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: Thank
goodness-- huh?
MELISSA MORALES: She
really-- yeah, yeah, yeah.
She really turned
that situation around.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
MELISSA MORALES:
OK, so now we'd like
to open it up for audience
Q&A. What questions do you
have for Lina?
AUDIENCE: The
story that you told
earlier about the husband
that got mad at the wife
for hitting him--
what other alternatives do you
think there-- because I almost
think, it's interesting
that you made the decision
to adhere to what he said
just to save your business.
But I'm wondering if that really
goes against the core values.
So I'm just curious--
what went through your head?
And what are the alternatives
that you thought?
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: Because I
think that's a tough decision.
I don't know if I'd have
made the same, but--
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah-- for sure.
If I had to, of course,
deal with him-- let's say,
stand against him and just
deal with it in court,
it's going to take years.
And he's a lawyer, so he has
connections inside the court.
That's something else.
Usually, men in
the Middle East--
I don't know if you
have that trouble--
but it's mostly about friends--
making friends.
I think it's everywhere.
But mostly, it happens
a lot between men,
because they have relatives
in the government.
They have-- so they know people.
And sometimes, just
standing up against that
will just drain your energy.
It's going to get you
to a point that you
want to shut down everything.
And it's going to fill you with
more anger, because society
is not helping.
So you think about
the smart decision.
Of course, we called her.
When we called her, she said,
I want to focus on my family.
It was her decision.
Like, she can get a
divorce if she wants.
But for us to protect our
students and business,
we have to act smart.
And sometimes, just
going against them--
it means that you're
losing a battle.
So in that environment, also--
for example, if you go
in the street and say,
I am asking for women's rights,
they can easily kill you.
It's not an easy environment.
And if you want to spread
the message on the long-term,
you need to exist
for a longer term.
You cannot go do something
crazy and suddenly--
what's your use in life if
they actually took you in jail?
You're not going to empower
a lot of other people.
So you need to be smart.
You need to make
a lot of friends.
Even-- like, you
cannot go, let's say,
just angry at the society.
I worked with Syrian
refugees a lot.
Also, Syrian refugees--
they have a lot of problems.
They have child marriage.
And of course, for me, it
pisses me off to see a child--
12-years-old-- getting
married, right?
But what I can do?
I cannot go and tell them,
you are doing something wrong.
You need to change that.
It's a culture.
You cannot change the
culture in one day.
It might take years, you know?
And what you do is,
just, you give examples.
You inspire them.
You empower the little
girls that, one day,
they can be something.
Because all they see is just
a crisis, like, just a war.
Or their father, probably,
is married to 20 women.
I don't know.
They have a lot of problems.
I worked with them
for, like, four years.
And you cannot go and just
go against them-- like,
you're doing something wrong.
You cannot do that.
Because they would
never listen to you.
They would leave.
They would say, who are you to
tell us to change that culture?
But what you want to do--
you want to act smart.
You want them to love you--
like, really love you-- so
they can listen to you--
so they can look at
you as a role model.
And that's what I
do-- how I do it.
I have a lot of men
supporting me in Jordan.
And they keep telling me,
you're our role model.
Because for me, also, having
the men's support is important,
because it's a male-dominated--
Middle East is very
male-dominated.
And you need men, also,
to back you up sometimes.
They have friends.
And it's fine.
I have a lot of
support from women.
I have from men--
like, I had a lot of
problems with the government.
But who helped me with it?
It was all my male friends.
And they're like, we need
to stop these haters.
And we're going to stand
up by you, because you're
doing something good.
And you need that support.
And you need to change
slowly, step-by-step.
You can't go and say,
like, we want our rights--
shouting, because no
one will listen to you.
So it's just different.
Being raised in the
Middle East is different.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for your talk.
So this is pretty ironic,
because the end of this month,
I'm going to Jordan too.
LINA KHALIFEH: Oh, [? great. ?]
AUDIENCE: First time ever
going to Middle East--
LINA KHALIFEH: You'll love it.
AUDIENCE: So yeah--
just wondering--
I don't know if it's true, but
the stereotype that the Middle
East-- it's a little dangerous.
And people have
been telling me--
LINA KHALIFEH: Oh, no--
Jordan is very safe.
AUDIENCE: OK-- so
I was wondering,
was that what inspired you
to get into self-defense?
I don't know.
And then, do you have any
tips for a woman going
to Jordan, especially someone--
LINA KHALIFEH: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: --who
doesn't look Jordanian?
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, Jordan
loves tourists a lot.
And yeah-- so you probably
want to go to Dead Sea, Petra--
there is a place--
you know the movie, "Martians"?
It was filmed in Jordan,
because it's all desert.
And we're supposed to be Mars.
I don't know.
And there's a camp there--
it's next to Petra--
where you can-- it
actually was started
with the film of "The Martian."
And then they left it there.
So it's like rounded houses,
where the ceiling's just open.
And you see the stars at night.
So definitely-- you do
it to work in Jordan.
They love tourists.
And they're very
friendly with tourists.
I'm a local.
So it's different.
I know there are
rules inside rules.
And just, that's why I know
about all the domestic violence
we have.
But with tourists, they're
just very welcoming.
You're going to see that.
But don't think now it's
hot in the Middle East.
Actually, with climate
change, it's changing.
We have a lot of
rain, flash floods.
And you definitely want to
be careful of flash floods.
If there is rain, don't
go to Dead Sea or Petra,
because there's going to be
just sudden flash floods.
But enjoy the food.
The food is good.
MELISSA MORALES: No, I
think it's interesting
what you mentioned-- like, the
juxtaposition of, you know,
the safety that maybe
one encounters out living
in the streets or in the world,
but then the very real dangers
that sometimes exist
behind closed doors, right?
LINA KHALIFEH:
Yeah, yeah-- it is.
MELISSA MORALES: Because
domestic violence--
there's a huge incidence
of it everywhere,
including the United States.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah,
yeah-- it's everywhere.
MELISSA MORALES: So we're
certainly not immune of it
here.
But I think, it just speaks to--
we think sometimes about--
maybe like the situation
that you described of
somebody literally attacking
you and trying to assault
you-- sexually assault you.
And obviously, those
situations are also real.
But there's just
such a myriad of
different nuanced
situations, where
you might find yourself actually
wanting to have these skills.
And maybe you
didn't think that--
it's maybe not like a scary
situation all of a sudden,
but something that
builds over time.
So anyway, just, I think
that's an interesting point--
the distinction
to be made, right?
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, definitely.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah,
OK, let's get in--
LINA KHALIFEH: A couple--
MELISSA MORALES: --a couple
more questions really quickly.
And then we can move on to the--
oh, oh, OK!
You have a question.
All right, Anthony,
let's hit it.
AUDIENCE: So I know
that you mentioned
that you were planning to
move your business over
to the United States.
Have you face any challenges
here in the United States
while doing that?
LINA KHALIFEH: So
should I mention--
OK.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: So
I'm also Canadian.
I have a Canadian passport.
That's why it's easier to move.
But I was in Seattle.
And I usually don't
have any problem
coming to the United States.
And I was stopped
by the Customs--
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: --or
the Passport Control,
asking me, for two
hours, like 100 questions
and just being so rude.
But it was just this
experience about the police,
maybe, in America.
I'm not sure later on.
But I still keep the
positive side of everything.
I mean, I've been to Pakistan.
I've been to Saudi Arabia.
I've been to many,
many countries.
I know that you're going to
face, sometimes, obstacles.
It's fine.
It's everywhere.
You have problems.
But it's just how you
look at it later on.
Sometimes, you have
to deal with it--
like, just deal with it.
Just be patient.
Do not really argue a lot
and try to get out of it.
MELISSA MORALES: Let me change
the framing of the question
a little bit and ask you about
it from a business perspective,
right?
LINA KHALIFEH: Oh, yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: Because
again, social entrepreneur--
You're out there.
You're trying to
build partnerships.
You're trying to get support
and meet the right folks.
Like, even already
in this room, there's
a couple of people who are
interested in working with you.
What are some of the
challenges that you're facing?
Or how can we, as an audience,
right here in the United
States, support you as you
try to grow your business
and bring it here to
the United States?
LINA KHALIFEH:
Sure-- for example,
I've never lived in
the United States.
That's number one.
So I would love to know more
about who I can connect with
or if there's working
spaces for women
or we can partner up-- or
all these important things--
how to build my team
in the United States.
In Seattle, there
were a couple of girls
who just came to my session.
And they're, like, CrossFit--
MELISSA MORALES:
Oh, yeah, yeah--
CrossFit, yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: And they're like,
we want to take your course.
MELISSA MORALES: It's a very
enthusiastic audience, yes.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah,
and they're like,
we've been following you a lot.
And it's important
for me to create
all these women who
love, first, fitness,
who love to empower other--
you don't have to have any
background also in fitness.
But if you want to change
other people's lives
or you want to empower them
through training self-defense
and teaching to a
younger generation,
I would just be
happy to communicate,
coordinate together.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: So I just
wanted to put that out
there for folks in the room
or folks who may be watching
on Livestream or later on.
If you're interested,
make sure to reach out.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, definitely.
You can reach out on
website, SheFighter.com.
MELISSA MORALES: Yes, perfect.
LINA KHALIFEH: Or we are
on all social media--
so at SheFighter
Instagram or Twitter.
MELISSA MORALES: Can't beat
that Instagram, you know?
LINA KHALIFEH: There's a
lot of Google on Instagram.
MELISSA MORALES: Slide
into the SheFighter DMs.
That's what she's saying.
OK, let's take
one more question.
We have a couple more minutes.
OK, we got one over here.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned some
of your individual supporters
for you trying to have a
women-empowering organization
in a male-dominated society.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you find any
allies in organizations?
And how did you engage with them
and support them the other way?
LINA KHALIFEH: Oh,
you mean in Jordan?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, definitely.
As I said, you're
going to have support.
You always have to look at
the good side all the time,
wherever you go.
Even if you go to really, really
countries that is under war,
you're going to have
support coming for you.
You need to just
make sure that you
are on good terms
with these people,
because they're going
to help you grow
and will help you also work
on your plan as you grow.
Definitely-- I work-- like
SheFighter is so big in Jordan,
anyway, we're covering schools.
We work with different
organizations
like UNHCR and all these
NGOs that we work with.
And everyone knows about us.
We've been there
for so many years.
And of course, men
and women support.
At the beginning, there
were not much people.
But as you start growing and
proving that your system is
actually working--
because people--
it's like your parents.
When you saw something,
they're like, eh--
you don't want to spend
a lot of time doing that.
And when you grow, you're
like, oh, you need our help?
We have to be part of it.
And it's exactly like--
but you have to know this.
Your journey is not
to prove to others.
Your journey is just, you have
to go through this in order
to grow inside yourself.
And once you do it, everything
else falls into pieces
and you're going to find
yourself inspiring thousands
of people or changing lives.
But you don't have to
worry about future.
You don't have to worry about
who's going to support or not.
You just keep going
with your path.
MELISSA MORALES: Hm.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MELISSA MORALES:
Yeah, that's hard.
It's easier said than done.
I will say that much.
LINA KHALIFEH: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: But I think--
yes, that's--
LINA KHALIFEH: It needs a lot of
dedication and self-confidence.
MELISSA MORALES: Yeah, yeah--
the confidence--
LINA KHALIFEH:
Confidence-- yeah.
MELISSA MORALES: --to believe
in your dream and your vision--
absolutely.
OK, well, let's thank Lina--
LINA KHALIFEH: Thanks.
MELISSA MORALES: --for her time.
LINA KHALIFEH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]